what's up GQ I'm James LaPorta I'm the
former US Marine infantryman and this is
the breakdown
[Music]
first up jarhead I don't even know how
many jarheads that they're up to now but
it has nothing to do with the original
jarhead
there is one jarhead all the others are
booked for a lack of a better term so
this is one of the more accurate movies
black or brown or yellow or red you are
now green before I've even started I'm
seeing things that are standing out to
me his haircut is correct when guys
enter boot camp the first thing you're
doing is you're getting your head shaved
the uniform is good it is accurate in
terms of the time period so early 90s
what is absolutely ugly is the back
barracks or her especially recruit
barracks are not that white it looks
like they're in a mental ward the
blankets are usually green they're like
these wool green blankets that look like
they're straight out of like the Cold
War so that is what stands out to me I
mean what is accurate is yeah the bunks
are made and that is exactly how you
would hang your towels usually some guys
they wouldn't even get under their bed
because when you're getting woken up at
like 3:30 4:00 in the morning by drill
instructors you don't have a lot of time
you have to everything is sort of on a
countdown and so they don't even get
under the covers they just sort of sleep
on top of their bed you know so it's
already made and they just have to sort
of straighten it up go back okay so that
is all accurate
that's called staining online you have
to do that a lot I used to hide behind a
stanchion if you're lucky your rack is
near one and so when the drill
instructor is sort of looking down the
line like that you can sort of like lean
back and hide and this there you don't
have those stations but that is accurate
in terms of guys on both sides sort of
staring at each other
not moving and you're just sort of
hoping nobody drill instructor doesn't
see you glancing down the line sir yes
sir yes again mother Jodi's banging her
right now get on your face and give me
25 she gets pause it in terms of the
yelling that that's accurate it sort of
depends on the person so because there's
been so many sort of incidents that have
happened there's a lot of oversight in
terms of the behavior of DRO instructors
like Joan truckers are not supposed to
be custom so a lot of drill instructors
you'll see you'll hear them get around
it like bad dog you know or something
like that but usually general trucker
would look around to make sure like no
higher-ups are there and they would you
know they'll still costs again mother
Jodi's banging her right now get on your
face and give me 25 for every time she
gets this month down on your face oh
let's go back Jodi is a real thing
Jodi in the Marine Corps is almost like
a urban myth Jodi is the person to wear
if you're deployed or you're a boot camp
or you're out the field training Jodi is
the guy who's back home taking your wife
out on a date or having sexual
intercourse with your girlfriend good at
drugs so you might sprite then these are
mice prime supposed to know how to draw
in terms of him being a scribe that's a
real thing there's also artist recruits
and so they draw all the art the
drawings are always something to deal
with either war or death that's what
they tend to draw for the drama friends
cuz they look cool think when I'm giving
you a few left tips you're going to fire
your rifle when grenades are going off
in your face we've been doing here sir
yeah that that's happened again not
commonplace amongst both phases and not
commonplace drone traders they actually
have a card in terms of how long they
can make a recruit do push-ups make it
recruit do sit-ups if there's a lot of
regulation but I mean even in perfect
worlds where there are systems in place
to not allow things to happen things
have
and like a drill instructor slamming
someone's head into a board it stop
right there this is even though this is
very subtle
this is incredibly accurate so this is
what is known as a boot drop so
basically what has occurred is these
Marines have graduated boot camp right
from there they'll have like a week off
I think it's like ten days and then from
there they'll go to the school of
infantry but the reason I wanted to
pause this is because there is a fear in
all these Marines and it's the same fear
that I had those Marines standing on
sort of the catwalks of the upper decks
are looking down at these brand-new guys
you can imagine some of them are already
veterans themselves from war and so
you're just staring at these guys who
are going to eat you alive I was
severely hazed sort of when I first
showed up to my first unit you know it
took me many many years to realize after
that that it was that they were dealing
with things that they probably had been
in therapy for it wasn't because me
being the new guy whose because they had
just come back from seeing their friends
died in Iraq
that is accurate it's one of those
things that is not commonplace across
the entire Marine Corps but has it
happened
absolutely so they'll take literally an
iron and they'll bend it into to spell
out USMC and they will brand people now
again this is not a commonplace thing I
did not see it in my time and I served
from 2006 to 2014 I've seen pictures of
it that is accurate for the early 90s
and even into the 80s I mean I wasn't
branded but something similar in terms
of sort of the gang mentality we were
training on the field I'm still a new
marine someone had found out that I had
a huge fear of snakes
I had six senior guys hold me down and
they found these snakes out in the woods
and I mean I was I was fighting tooth
and nail it was at least one that he put
on my chest
and I was freaking out you know and then
someone said hey guys knock it off we
gotta go have a we have a briefing to go
to you know within the field before we
were supposed to run our range so again
I didn't get branded but that is sort of
mentality of like the senior guys
ganging up on a new guy that's accurate
next up stripes right right left right
you stay in place left right left right
left right left right left but hi all
right let's rewind that
so in marching you're supposed to start
on your left foot everything has some
sort of meaning behind it you're judged
down to the inch you know in terms of
badges and ribbons have to be at a
certain inch the guy in front of you is
supposed to be 40 inches from your chest
everything has a structure to it but it
takes a while for some people to get the
hang of marching general searchers have
a couple of tricks because at boot camp
it's not just the recruits that are
getting judged the higher Command
Authority is actually judging the drone
structures themselves so drill is a huge
part of that so far everything is
accurate there is a comedic element guys
looking around like laughing and stuff
like that there'd be a drill sergeants
probably screaming at them
[Music]
posit while a funny scene no guys gonna
just start singing the drill sergeant is
in charge of that and if some random
recruit just started singing in the
middle of his formation he wouldn't be
singing for long do we sing yes singing
is common in the military across the
military services
you wouldn't belt out if the right
senior enlisted soldier or marine or
officer is standing around because it is
incredibly violent
alright let's fast-forward
[Music]
pause scribe this is very much like a
director like let's make it look like a
really active military base where you
know there's formations going every
which way it happens but it's like it's
comes off as fake to me all these tanks
driving behind all these formations and
you know all at the same time cuz you
got to think about it bases themselves
are also small cities there are tons of
civilians that work on base
yeah overall they got the basic idea
right but they are taking what we would
call artistic liberties next up Hacksaw
Ridge it's a true story
Desmond Doss yep middle one recipient
world war true you and so he served as a
combat medic but at that time combat
medics didn't carry weapons they just
tended the wounded they wanted to put
him on the frontlines and be in the
infantry and he was a conscientious
objector and went to a court-martial but
he won constitutionally they were the
army was trying to were violating his
rights but he went on to earn the Medal
of Honor yeah so real story and a crazy
story those Oscars I've seen them really
depends on the base but those are common
even you know the the sort of where they
have to climb up and go down these are
specifically called circuit courses or
could even pass for the O course which
is an obstacle course
so yeah especially if it's like a timed
event you know you have this long to get
through the obstacle course so he's got
a clipboard right there it's a timed
event so yeah people are racing to try
to get the best time a heartbreaker age
yeah oh oh it kills me about this the
one thing I've never been able to live
down about this movie is if I remember
correctly there supposed to be a camp
lejeune there is not a single mountain
near Camp Lejeune North Carolina
obviously they're in California that
ruins it for me
accurate this is not boot camp they're
already in the fleet
they're shooting m16 a one's came out of
the Vietnam War a lot of people don't
know that the lower half of an m16a1 in
Vietnam what is plastic and actually it
was developed by Mattel so this is all
Akron's this is a regular firing range
it's common in both boot camp and in the
fleet so what's not accurate is you'd
have way more people because you know
shooting guns safety is paramount and
things can go wrong when people start
shooting weapons so that's why there'd
be way more people that's accurate so it
was called the Pitts and actually that
one guy one person just put up a
lollipop there are these carriages down
there in the pits you can see them
there's Marines down there they're
putting targets up those are point
targets and they're bringing them down
so someone shoots they'll bring it down
the mark where the shot was and they'll
put it back up and show where the
shooter shot but that's all accurate
there's a red line in the pits and if
you stay behind that red line you won't
get shot however I was on the range once
a drill instructor got shot in the leg
so the ground hit the carriage that
liked that either the left or right side
of the carriage that's holding the
target and and ricocheted and hit him in
the leg despite him being behind the red
line keep it tight
first I want to know what I would love
to know what yard line where he hit that
so we shoot from the 200 yard line the
300 and the 500 yard line it's because
I'm questioning that accuracy putting
that aside people flagging the line
happens all the time
and it is scary they lack muzzle
awareness they lack just common sense
thinking of like I need to keep my
weapon pointed downrange I mean they
would be immediately kicked off the
range because that is incredibly
egregious and incredibly dangerous but
yeah that happens a lot what is in actor
right there is for his rough as
indisciplined as Clint Eastwood's
character is and he's trying to instill
discipline into this recon platoon he
would not have them walking around
without their chin straps undone vain if
you ever watched John Wayne movies he
always had his chin strap undone middle
of combat and somehow his helmet never
falls off all right next up Full Metal
Jacket Holly Emery was there's a great
story about how he sort of worked his
way into getting this role he was the
military advisor for Stanley Kubrick on
on this movie he was not meant to be in
the movie but the actor that they had
hired to be the drill instructor it just
wasn't
that and polyamory was in the Marine
Corps was a staff sergeant and was a
drill instructor in real life and he
just had that sort of rhythm Joe
instructors have a certain rhythm to how
they speak how they yell Joe instructors
are putting on a character nobody's
walking around angry all the time like
that you know that don't you sir yes sir
if it wasn't gifts like you that would
be anything in this world would there
sir no sir
well now let's just see if there's
anything missing that is no different
from them to when I went through boot
camp in 2006 that is completely accurate
there have been many uh people who have
gotten their complete footlocker wrecked
by a drone trucker I've seen complete
rooms wrecked by drill instructors for a
towel being at a place or a rack not
being made correctly and so if there's a
footlocker that was unlocked well we got
to see if anything is missing and they
are going to dump yours all over the
floor and then they're gonna give you
like 30 seconds to collect it all and to
put it back in the same order usually if
it happens the one person it's going to
happen to the rest of 'la tuned you do
everything as a unit there isn't an
individual everything is done as a team
and so if one person is getting punished
at some point the rest of the - it's
gonna get punished so you're only as
strong as your weakest link that's sort
of the whole idea but uh dro instructors
it's actually a really really hard life
you don't truckers their first cycle
lose an incredible amount of weight I
knew one guy who lost literally like 30
pounds inside of three months I mean
because it was just non-stop your job is
really to make everyone's life miserable
and just to go around and yell all the
time
pause absolutely accurate when he says
you have not given private pyle the
proper motivation there is a subtext to
that he's speaking in code for one jelly
doughnut now get on your faces
open your mouth their fans for you eat
hazing will be disguised by other names
such as training or motivation but what
they really mean is we need to haze him
into compliance and that's what he's
really saying there and once got I think
it was nine stitches under this eye I
wasn't doing a push-up right I got
kicked in the face by a private who I
out ranked but he had been to Iraq and I
hadn't so despite me out ranking him I
didn't in terms of the social hierarchy
full-metal-jacket overall is is accurate
especially for the time so this is
occurring during Vietnam
full-metal-jacket is probably
responsible for recruiting tons of
Marines into the Marine Corps it's the
movie I watched when when they're
thinking about going into the Marine
Corps they look at Full Metal Jacket you
know or they look at Full Metal Jacket
they're like well I'm not gonna go in
the Marine Corps gonna go in the Air
Force or the Navy you know some of their
service there were some egregious
moments but most of what I saw is taken
from real life and I think when you know
when when service members or veterans or
you know looking at TV shows are looking
at military movies that's sort of what
we're looking forward even if that
didn't happen to us as long as it falls
into the realm of something that could
happen or that realm of possibility
we'll let it slide but we can't let
slide a lot of times is you know ribbons
being out of place you know and that's
where it's sort of like why didn't you
just do a little bit of research before
you started writing a script and that's
where it drives us insane I'm James
LaPorta thank you for watching the
breakdown
[Music]